hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar recent
advances for simultaneous analysis to
determine embryo pgta
and pgtm status within gs i am jennifer
woods of labyrinths and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
jingus
ginolu phd founder and ceo
of nextgen genetics
uh dr do you know you may now begin your
presentation
perfect thank you so much jennifer for
the research for action
um my name is jennifer ginolgo
and i would like to thank thermal fisher
for having me to discuss the most recent
advantages
advances in pgta implantation genetic
testing world
so this is my disclosure i'm a founder
and the ceo of nextgen genetics
today i would like to cover uh these
topics
uh first i would like to start uh pgta
technologies
and i would like to mainly focus on
represent the verification
and i would like to also talk about one
of the reasons the most hot topic about
embryo mosaicism and how we are able to
able to do
this analytical testing with the
reproductive platform
and we will also go over a little bit
the the cutoff values to
them to understand how the embryo
mosaicism called
in the field and then we will we will
release a few papers
related those topics um and that towards
at the end of the talk i will be mainly
talking about
advantages of using ripper 6 platform
and
compared to others that are currently
available in our field
once the pgta talk is done then i would
like to change its
subject to pre-implantation genetic
testing for single gene disorders
and first i would like to actually start
with current testing platform that i
have been
utilized in our field and i will start
with the linkage analysis with the short
tandem repeats
and then continue with the career
mapping this is snip based array
technology
and but i would like to mainly focus on
ngs based pgtm with pgt6
and how we verify the technology through
actually
thermal efficient platform and at the
end again i will also discuss the
advantage of using this pgt sig
over any other current platform that are
you just live in the field
so again i'd like to start with the
pre-implementation genetic testing for
unemployed each
and explain the most recent advances in
our actual field
so i put the slide just to give you a
little bit an idea about
ngs platform so um there's
probably a misconception or field there
is not only one ngs platform
in the field there are actually multiple
of them each actually
technology actually come up with the
brilliant idea to be able to sequence
samples um some of the actually
technologies actually has a high
throughput
but actually low coverage or low
actually the
readings versus some of facial other
technology has
no throughput that has a high actually
sequencing grids
so it depends of actually um our needs
that are multiple
ngs platform uh that are currently
in in in the field but when it comes to
pre-implantation genetic testing that
aren't
allowed and that are on the fee platform
that has the full solution which i will
discuss
uh ripposig platform uh is gonna be one
of my main topic
today so
before actually i jump into the ngs
technology and how the ngs works first i
would like to quickly go over
how we do the testing in an embryonic
level so
as we all know when the embryo actually
ready in the blast as a stage
for biopsy and the embryo has a two main
compartment one of them is
inner cell mass which is eventually
gonna be the the baby
and also the trophectoderm which is this
is gonna be eventually placenta of the
baby
so what we know is that removing fuel
cell from profectodorm
it doesn't harm the embryo and by
getting feed cells from this
part we'll be able to understand the
genetic makeup of those embryos
but as we all know each cell contains
approximately six picogram of dna which
if five or six cells are removed from
traffictodor
we don't have actually enough dna to
start with to use
in any platform so in order for us to be
able to actually
increase the dna yield we actually use a
technology called whole genome
amplification
so once we get those few cells from
biopsied embryos
we first like the cells and then once
the dna is available
we actually do the amplification to be
able to increase the yield thousands of
thousands times that we can use any
platform
for the genetic testing so once we
actually dna
is available then what we do is we
actually
fragment the dna in small pieces and
they are approximately 100 to 200 base
pair
and we put like small adapters that
allow us to be able to start sequencing
a library and those each small fragment
will be actually sequenced millions of
millions of time
and at the end we will actually get all
the small pieces and compared to
reference dna which has come from the
human genome project
to be able to understand copy number for
each chromosome
uh for embryonic levels
so one of the actually advantages with
next generation sequencing that we did
not have before with other platforms
such as
ray cgh or slippery is the barcode
if you think about actually next
generation sequencing has been around
for last
six or seven years but previously we
were using
um in the early stage early
stage of this genetic testing analysis
we used to use actually a fish
technology so as an incident
hybridization
but of course this is not molecular
approach when we move to molecular
approach we start using array cgh or
sniper ray
and i believe they did really good job
in the past the only problem with those
platform we did not have actually
barcoding system that we can actually
do simultaneous analysis multiple
samples in the same reaction
with connectionary sequencing we are
actually able to barcode every single
sample
and initially we had we were able to
only
mix up 24 sample and we were able to
sequence them in parallel but now
we are able to actually um barcode 96
samples
and after the barcoding we can pull all
of them in a single tube and we can do
parallel
sequencing for each sample which reduces
the cost significantly
um but other big advantages which next
generation sequencing is the higher
dynamic range
now just because of the high resolution
we used to actually call the embryos
normal or abnormal like as if
everything is black and white which we
know that when it comes to biology
nothing is in black and white
now with this due to higher dynamic
range we are able to also look at
the mosaic status of the embryos
although we are calling like mosaic
status but some scientists would like to
use intermediate results some scientists
would like to use potato mosaic so but
whatever we call them now
due to with these newer technologies
with the ngs we are able to again not
only call any blood and utility but also
on the status of the andres as well
and again due to higher resolution we
can also identify small segmental
rearrangements which help us
to be able to also do all the testing
for a translocation
cases and like as i mentioned one of the
important part is also the cost
and now compared to any other previous
platform
such as rach or sniper ray um the cost
is significant to lower with
uh next generation sequencing with that
actually many actually people actually
will have an access to those such
technologies
so till recently we were discussing
whether or not pgta should be actually
should be used uh in our field um
and but i think this discussion pretty
much is over now the question is not
really whether or not we should be using
pgk technology for
embryo or any other analysis the the the
other question is how does ngs
technology can actually access those
mosaic
embryos which is intermediate results
where they are not normal and they are
not abnormal
now before i jump into the mosaic embryo
analysis i would like to just go over
what is mosaic embryos by definition
finding
more than one distinct chromosomal
account in a sample
and the reason of those mosaic embryos
it could be
either due to anaphase lack or mitotic
misex segregation of the chromosome or
premature cell division before the dna
replication
so the timing of the misaggregation it's
also affect the severity of the
mosaic embryos and if you look at
actually from the published paper
incidents of euploid and iplode and
mosaicism varying
as low as two percent and as high as 30
percent in the blastocyst stage
um what we know actually even from
prenatal specimen
um i'm nearly we are finding up to 0.25
percent
in american fluid and also up to two
percent in chronically like sampling
so the mosaic is definitely effect now
we still have actually a lot of unknown
about a mosaic embryos like as i said
some scientists doesn't want to
necessarily want to call those mosaic
ambrose as a mosaic
they want to call them intermediate
result which i would not disagree with
this
because when we called mosaic embryos we
don't even really know
how many embryos are truly mosaic how
does biopsy correlate
to those inner cell mass and also how
does actually
the the biopsies actually affect even
overall
mosaic embryos um the way that we
grow the embryos or handling the embryos
doesn't impact the
overall mosaic results and when we
transfer those mosaic embryos and when
we have a
healthy babies are they really truly
normal so with this actually today
webinar will
kind of try to answer some of those
questions that we just like listed in
here
so before we talk about like a day five
embryo mosaicism
i would like to actually quickly touch
base on mosaicism on day three
um until recently all the genetic
testing
effort was done on day 3 embryo
development
um and ideally in the day 3m
redevelopment you have a typically
eight cell and just by chance one cell
made the white abnormally
and in case the biopsy is done with this
purple cell which is the unemployed cell
and the result obviously will come
abnormal whereas
just by chance if the euploid cell was
removed
the result will come like normal but if
you look at actually this scenario
in both cases the result is correct but
both of them doesn't represent the whole
embryo just because of this embryo
mosaicism
in fact in the past when we
were doing day 3 biopsy and then we were
doing re
analysis on day 3. in some cases we were
finding the abnormal result was
corrected on day 5
and i don't believe the result was
corrected i don't think the embryo is
going to be suddenly smart and
try to correct by himself i think what
happens is that
if the euploid embryos is removed and
the sister cells is the only one is
going to remain in the embryo so by
removing the aneploid cells
we're basically cleaning the embryo and
if the sister cells
die out at some point the embryo will
have only good cells which is euploid
cells
satellites and if you ever do another
biopsy in day 5 or md6
result will come back normal now the
question is
is the technology is incorrect or it's
just like biology is kind of giving us
those
uh results which are unfortunate because
they either
false negative or false positive results
so
i think we really did good job when we
were doing day three biopsies not that
i'm suggesting that we should go back to
the
three biopsies but i think um
if you look at what's happening with day
five biopsies
i don't think a lot of things have
changed since then
when it comes to embryo mosaicism and i
remember in when we were doing day 3
biopsies
we were hearing actually from scientific
paper 15
of those day 3 embryos are mosaic so we
decided to actually stop doing d3
biopsies just because of its only single
cell and it will move to day five biopsy
because we believe that the mosaic
system on the front is definitely less
but if you look at actually uh those
scenarios
um the mosaic system actually it can be
a
kind of the difference in for each
scenarios
so in some cases referred to them could
be affected but not the
icm inner cell mass or sometimes half of
the icm is affected
but not the trophic term or in some
cases only perfected or affected but not
the icm
so unfortunately we are still facing
those embryos and even on day
day five uh the embryo and embryo
development
and in fact those kind of scenarios very
well well studied
in the the capables and his colic with
the 2016 paper
he showed that some of the actual
mosaics can be reciprocals some of them
can be
uniform so it depends actually which
part of the embryo is taken obviously
we're not going to touch the the anus
almost for obvious reasons
but we still actually have chance to be
getting those mosaic cell lines
and which may or may not represent the
whole embryo
now if the embryo mosaicism is
it has a high frequency then the
question is why we are doing in
even the testing in the first place what
we know actually if the biopsy presents
the whole embryo
pgta result is extremely accurate in
fact
a paper that was published in 2010 it's
a little bit like old paper
but i am also one of the co-author in
this paper and we actually did the study
from with the donated embryos where
um we did the analysis
by removing inner cell mass from the
embryo
and and the leftover embryo was split in
two to be able to look at those
concordance rates between trophectoderms
and trophactoderm and icm concordance
rate with that specific
paper um when we look at the trifecta
dorm biopsies
we found hundred percent concordance
between all the traffic to the results
but when we compare the traffic to the
result were in a cell mass
we found 96.1 percent concordance rate
which was quite high
um and also that kind of tells us this
genetic testing working in the membranic
level
but what we also find at 3.9 percent of
time
the trophectoderm may not present the
whole inner cell mass with the rest of
the embryo
which unfortunately it may cause false
negative or for posters but
unfortunately
the reality that we have to live with
now a little bit actually more kind of
review about embryo mosaicism
so what we know actually uh when it
comes to embryo mosaicism or
those intermediate results um
there are different algorithms and
different kind of values may impact the
overall result
if the cut of values is very low or high
then
the mosaic and the result will kind of
differ depending on where you put the
cut off
and with that said that pgas really
helped
to our ivf goal and again the same
question
when we actually call an embryo is
mosaic or intermediate result or
potential mosaic
are they really all actually mosaics uh
and what is the technical contribution
and where do we go from there now what
we know is actually there is another
research
field as already started for the last
few years in non-invasive tree
implantation genetic testing for an
airplane which is this is not the
today topic but based on those new
research
the the culture media where the embryos
actually go may have a better
representation of the whole embryo
rather than just removing these cells
from trifecta
now i would like to actually go a little
bit deep inside of this like embryo
mosaicism call and how those actually
the call was made
based on uh different genetic labs um
so it's not actually about the like when
we make
the mosaic embryo call this is not about
mainly
which gene ngs platform we are using it
is mainly dependent of the
the operator and the cutoff values uh
in some labs you may have the cutoff
value anywhere between
lower cut off is 20 and higher cutoff is
to 80.
and another hand some other cutoff
values goes to anywhere from 30 to 70.
so obviously if you go with those lower
cutoff
versus higher cutoff then is 10 10
percent
a clear difference in here and if you
are using lower cut off obviously you
will have more mosaic ambiance
or more intermediate results again what
we know is that
obviously ngs platform has definitely
some kind of
impact on the overall result but the lab
protocols catalyst algorithm ultra
multiplication protocol
all unfortunately contribute to all
embryo mosaicism all
and as far as i know there is not really
kind of really standardization in our
field
and when you look at all the papers that
are recently published
varying cutoffs let the percentage of
the mosaic embryos reported anywhere
from five percent to twenty percent
and if you think about five to twenty
percent that are fifteen percent
differences
in the embryo mosaicism calls
now i would like to actually um
[Music]
quickly touch base on pgtis guideline
and in 2016 pg daischekly
published the guideline for transferring
mosaic embryos
um if you look at their recommendation
i'm pretty much agree with everything
that they actually recommended
and they recommend all the transfer
mosaic embryos if the couples so the
patient doesn't have an alternative
embryo exists and transferring mosaic
embryos should be done only with
with proper genetic counseling but the
disagreement that i have actually this
time by my personal opinion is the
technical colors
so initial cutoff values actually was
given 20
or less should be considered normal and
any time there is elevation
from over 20 percent all the way to 80
percent that will be considering
a mosaic calls or intermediate results
and anything more than 80 percent should
be considered abnormal
and they actually give also some
transfer priority
should be giving them mosaic monozmi for
obvious reasons with the few exceptions
over the present
embryos but in 2019
the same pdi guideline actually had that
pretty much everything same remain the
same except the technical cutoff values
has actually changed from
20 to 40 in my opinion 20
was low cut off and we need to keep in
mind that
all the technologies that we are using
are not perfect
uh especially whole genome application
and time to time or embryo biopsy
may contribute unfortunately those kind
of like noisy noisy actually reading
and having 20 cutoff may be confused
actually with mosaicism call
but at the same time uh pgdis in 2019
actually they increased the the lower
cutter values to from 20
to 40 percent in my opinion again 20
was low and i believe 40 percent is high
after the reason is that uh probably
we're gonna start to see
more implantation failures if the couple
ever transferred those mosaic embryos
and um because or the implantation
failure or actually
implantation with some miscarriage due
to the high cut of
uh holes on those embryos
now i would like to actually kind of
slightly
uh switch the the subject from those
mosaic embryo holes to
analytical verification that we have
done with the
uh by the research base with the corial
cell lines uh to
actually look at the represent protocol
with thermo fisher
um what we did was in our laboratory we
actually purchased corial sunlight those
are commercially available
and there are plenty actually normals
and abnormals normal phase and
a normal female and the cell line that
can be actually used for the analytical
verification
and here in this slide you could see
actually two profiles i would like to
start the ones on the top
this is actually normal for the six xx
normal female
that we process from korea so with this
profile i would like to explain you what
you're seeing here
with the x-axis you would see the number
goes from
everything from chromosome 1 all the way
to chromosome 22
and then we have the 6 of the m this
cell line which is
in this case is x and x if you look at
the y
axis uh the number goes from 0 all the
way to 3.5
so in order for us to call anything is
normal
we need to have two copies one copy come
from matanov and one copy come from
paterno site
and any deviation from those numbers
would be considered abnormal
so obviously those are actually a
control sample we know what they are
we actually removed a few cells from
those
um real cell lines and pretend uh as if
they are like single cell or two cells
or five cells
and we run them on our reprosec protocol
and we were able to get
picture perfect nice clear normal male
and female
if you look at the second one actually
this one is the normal male the only
difference obviously between normal
male and female is the there is an extra
y chromosome
in the male profile and again all the
chromosomes are listed in here those are
picture perfect two copies for every
single chromosome
now yes we can detect the normal and uh
male or female now the question is how
are we gonna be able to detect those uh
abnormal uh cell line again we also
purchased the coriol cell lines
abnormal uh for analytical verification
and um we actually had monozymex
as you can see in here in the circles in
the first picture
we have two copy for every single
chromosome except there is only one x
and there is no y
we also had um some chromosome
where there was an addition and in this
case we have a trisomy 13.
as you guys know um when we have an
addition
uh those are actually indication for
trisomy and there is a missing
chromosome
that is indication for monozone so with
the second example the ones in the
middle has
47 chromosome and there is a trisomy 13
and instead of having two copy there are
actually three copies
again those are really really nice
crystal clear picture perfect
profiles um those are
good actually dna quality and when you
have actually a very nice
good dna quality those technologies
pretty much always works
and the last one is actually trisomy 18
where there's an addition for chromosome
18 and it's also detected with the blue
circle
at the end
now we are able to detect those full
gain or losses
but how about those segmental errors are
we able to detect those segmental errors
we also purchase
some of the corial shell lines that has
those segmental errors for analytical
verification purpose
i would represent protocol and the first
one actually as you can see
it's 46xy and there's the duplication on
and chromosome 3.
and this is approximately 62.2 megabase
duplication and uh as you can see in
here
the the the on the chromosome 3 it is
not there is no complete gain it's just
like part of the segment
is duplicated but if you look at
actually the second one we said like
what is all resolution like how low we
can go and we will be still able to
detect those deletion sort of
applications
if you look at the the second example
where there we have a deletion on
chromosome 18
that specific cell line had seven
megabytes pollution and as you can see
in here we can still detect seven
megabits resolution which is quite high
with resolution and the last one is on
the chromosome
9 then in the p arm there is actually
duplication
and we were also able to detect with the
four media based duplication for
segmental letters
um being able to take those segments
really important because
we will be able to also address those
some of the translocation cases that
happens
in the airport
perfect now with the art now we know we
can detect those
full gain or losses and we can detect
the segmentals
but now the question is how about
mosaic holes are we going to be able to
detect those so what we did was in order
to
address this mosaicism detection we did
also again analytical verification by
artificially mixed corial sunlight
because
from korean sunlight you cannot really
buy
mosaic cell lines i mean there are
actually some mosaics
satellites are currently available but
we want to do the control analysis where
we mixed up two cell lines that we know
what they are
and if you look at with the first
example we have trisomy 13
x y 30 and resume 18 we put 70
and again this is not my actually a real
software but if i had a real software
if we actually zoom in in every single
chromosome you would be able to see the
percentage-wise whether or not they are
20 percent mosaic or 70 percent
motivation
we also mixed two another two different
cell lines where we had monotony x
and normal xy we mixed up with 50 50
and you can see the gender how they look
like that look like
two copies of x and then one copy of y
uh y chromosome and then we also mixed
up 50 50 with trisomy 13 and 18
and with all the kind of like experiment
that we did
we actually convinced ourselves that
those motivation detection can be done
with the process
perfect so one of the advantages of
using riprosic is as follows
so the the whole refreshing protocol
takes approximately 16 hours
and we do only um three hours hands-on
which is um which is kind of really good
because
less this human actually involvement is
that that means the left
actually uh the human
error in our lab so the two thirds of
the workflow
are pretty much done with the liquid
handler which is called iron chef
and the sequencing device and
and this is the device that you can see
in the
right hand side so this is the device
that i'm just mentioning
uh once we have the three hours
satellites
and whole genome multiplication protocol
is completely done
and pretty much to the rest of the tutor
the workflow will be done with handlers
and the sequencing device to be able to
complete
all the analysis
due to the high resolution as i
mentioned we are able to actually detect
all the segmental rearrangements uh to
address all the
translocation cases um but for me is one
of the
big advantage of using reprosec is first
of all is
lab user friendly and what i mean by
that is that
we are using uh 96 samples in each run
and unlike the other platform
we do not really have to measure every
single dna and normalize them
and then put them in the same actually
tube to be able to do the
in parallel sequencing so one of the big
advantages with reprodig is
once you do the whole genome
amplification you don't even have to
measure every single dna
you just take a look what which is five
four microliter from each sample
and you pull them in a single tube and
that's how you kind of continue with the
sequencing
which if you think about like really
measuring 96 samples
and once you get the measurements if you
have to really do the dilution
based on their measurement it takes a
lot of time and effort
and the problem there will be a lot of
human errors with those process
boundary also big advantage with
dropresic is there is a detailed
chromosome analysis
uh and with this actually software where
there's an optional actual embryo mosaic
called with the iron reporter software
and again one of the most important
things i mentioned
the less human involvement that means
less error
due to this liquid handler which called
like irish
one another big advantage with represent
is
the integration um as you can imagine
every time we sequence
an embryo or any sample we get like
massive data
we get a lot of information um obviously
we cannot really answer those like
manually
so the integration for us was really
crucial
and uh with actually ion reporter with
thermofisher
they have actually a very nice
integration system that whichever
database that you use uh due to their
integration system you can easily
actually transfer all the information
automatically
to your database that you don't actually
have to type or you have to
actually write anything the way that we
used to do it in the past
so as you can see here the ones actually
on the top this is our
database and for each embryo that we get
result
they will be automatically dumped into
the
database that we are using and obviously
we still check
uh all the results against the profile
that we received just to make sure that
we are not missing anything or nothing
has been
actually missed during this transfer
again i want to bring this actually
video again
because this is one of my favorite
device and i just wanna
play the the video again um
this is liquid handler and called the
iron shaft this protocol takes
approximately five hours
from the beginning all the way to the
end which takes a lot of burden
uh from any lab uh but one of the
actually big advantage with this system
is
uh you can actually customize or you can
program this robot
based on your lab workflow like for
instance
um when the the whole uh run is
completed five hours later
that chip that needs to be actually
transferred to the next generation
sequencing platform
uh but if you don't have any person and
when the run is completed
then what you could do is actually with
this ihf you can program this
to overnight running and then you can
program it for following day in the
morning
so the device will work all day long all
night alone
and then when you come back to the lab
the
the
chip will be ready actually to to upload
to to next generation sequencing device
um another good thing about withdraw
device as long as you kind of
do the maintenance adult device doesn't
have a good taste on bad days
the human being and just because of
those devices
the human error rate was the significant
radius
or minimized
okay so after all this reproductive
information i would like to review a
couple papers
that i would like to go over in terms of
the concordance rate between near cell
mass and traffic today
and concordance rate between mosaic
embryo cold and the mosaic embryo
transfer and some of the
outcomes
so this is one of the most recent papers
like as i mentioned earlier
although we did not have a lot of data
point
at the beginning now with this recent
few papers now we have actually more
information about those
cutoff values in the mosaic embryo
transfer
and i would like to start with the paper
that was published with with dr
vyoti and in 2020 in his colleague
um they use the cut-off values about 20
to 80 percent
like as i mentioned uh 20 could be a
little bit
low and uh but that's what the paper
actually mentioned there
the cutoff is anywhere between 20 and 80
and they were able to also categorize
those embryos
low mosaic or high mosaic no mosaic
means
if the south has like less than 50
percent or more than 40 percent
at those unemployed samples unemployed
actually cells in the embryo and that's
how they were
categorized um if you look at the
overall results and the euploid embryo
has a better actually better outcome
compared to combined mosaic embryos or
single chromosomal racism
which is kind of expected and when you
look at the spontaneous abortion
uh with the euploid embryos it's about
about eight percent
but with the any mosaic embryo transfer
the the outcome was slightly was higher
when it comes to spontaneous abortion
which is 20.4 percent and
25 and in this paper
uh they categorize the embryos and two
sides one is lower mosaic
where um we assume that lower mosaicism
meaning that
we have more healthy cells compared to
abnormal cells and if if the embryo has
actually more than 50
mosaics mosaicing that means we have
more abnormal cells and less
actually healthy cells and when those
transfer was done
lower mosaices versus hypermosaicism at
the implantation actually
a significant difference between the
lower mosaic embryos
had a higher implantation and the
ongoing pregnancy compared to high
mosaic embryos
um the assumption again with the lower
mosaicism
we have like more healthy cells compared
to abnormal
cells but one thing that i also want to
emphasize or actually mention
is that if you have a low cut of values
like 20
of course i'm speculating don't know the
answers some of those low mosaic
embryos may not be even actually mosaic
in the first place
and that was the reason maybe we were
getting some successful result from
those
low mosaic embryos compared to a higher
mosaic one
and in the same paper they looked at the
the embryo mosaicism type whether or not
low high whether or not they are
complete chromosome gain or losses
or whereas they are segmented moses and
what they found with specifically with
this paper
segmental mosaic actually had the better
outcome compared to
um any other actually for chromosome
gainer losses
but overall combining with the mosaic
level whether or not high or low
and the type of thermostatism again
whether or not this is full
full chromosome gain or losses or
segmentals
and with the combination of embryo
morphology has significantly actually
affected the likelihood the positive
outcome
this is another actually not necessarily
a paper a small abstract
i really wanted to put this just to kind
of show you
when you use lower cutoff 20 versus 30
and the uppercut of 70 versus 80 just
because of depends on where you put
those cutoff values
uh depending those cutoff values the
percentage authorization embryos report
reported anywhere from 4.9
to 17 which there is actually 12 percent
difference in between two numbers
so with this paper the the
the assumption is it's not about like
which next generation
technology you are utilizing it is the
most important thing is where
the cutoff will be placed and due to
high cutoff values
and the one genetic lab may have a
higher euploidy
compared to other genetic lab for
obvious reasons depends on
where you put those thresholds
um this is another interesting paper
that also show
the value of genetic testing pgta
time to time we get requests to for
re-biopsy embryos
when you look at the specific paper they
look at the concordance between the
first and second biopsy in mosaic embryo
results
when they look at actually those
re-biopsy on euploid embryos the
concordance rate was quite high
at 9.5 percent which is really amazing
and when they look at the unemployed
result
they were also really quite high which
is 97.3 percent
but if you ever do re-biopsy on mosaic
embryos the the concordance rate is
quite low which is about 35.2 percent
if the first patch becomes mosaic
chromosome 5
and if you were to do another biopsy you
may get the same result or you may get
like
another maybe a mosaic chromosome but
that's the reason we are calling those
envious mosaic um and that's why every
time you do another biopsy
probably you may end up with a different
percentage
but that's why we call them mosaic and
it's not about which result we should
trust all the results is correct
it's just the endless way itself is
mostly
so after talking a lot of about
pre-implantation genetic testing for
aneeplody i would like to talk about
pre-implantation genetic testing for
single gene disorder
and this is gonna be my next topic and
the last topic
um so i would like to actually quickly
go over
overview about what has been currently
done
for singles in disorder in our field so
all the initial
effort for single gene disorder is
mainly done either with linkage analysis
or direct mutation analysis and actually
often is combination of both
but all the initial effort for the
single gene this order was done with the
short tandem repeat
str analysis so as we know the genome
has
exon which is the coding region and
intron which is non-codic regions
and there are a lot of actually str are
located in the intro region
they are just keep repeating some of the
actual repeat can be
a four base pair it can be like a c t
a a c t a keep repeating a few times
um we don't know why they are even exist
in the intron but we have been using
those for all different kind of purposes
str short tandem repeat has been widely
used in fluorescent application
but we are using sdn analysis for
linkage analysis in case
uh we want to do direct mutation
analysis but just because of
the dna that we are working with require
whole genome amplification and
unfortunately whole genome amplification
there are some limitations some part of
the genome may not work and
the part that we are interested in if it
doesn't amplify
then we have to be actually using
linkage analysis to understand which
homolog chromosome goes from parents to
their embryonic level
um recently single nucleotide
polymorphism has been introduced to the
our field
and this is mainly illumina infinium 2
snip
array and uh this callback
array based linkage by cardio mapping uh
with this technology
this specific array consists of three
hundred thousand
snip and uh to be able to do the linkage
analysis
so single nucleated polymorphism
actually more common than the sdrs
in the genome and it's estimated uh four
to five million snips can be found
throughout the whole genome that can be
utilized for forensic application or any
linkage analysis
and the last one that i want to discuss
which is the the technology that i'm
currently using through thermo fisher is
called pg
gcsec and this is still snip based
approach but instead of using array
platform we're going to be using a
next generation sequencing for language
analysis
so i would like to start with linkage
analysis with sdr
um like as i mentioned before the sd
analysis basically where
the there are some repeats and every
human being carry
two chromosomes one come from one come
from your dad
and with that specific example let's
assume that
mom has acc repeat so this is only one
str marker that i would like to give an
example
and as you can see one of the allele
with the mom has five repeats
acc is repeating five times the second
allele
for the same one as in the second
chromosome has
several uh repeats if you look at that
that has six and seven repeats and again
this is only one str markers that i'm
talking about
so now the mom has heterozygous
five seven and that is heterozygous six
and seven repeats
so the possible allyson membranic level
would be either five to six
seven sort of five to seven sixty seven
or seventy seven repeats
those are the possible alleles in the
embryonic level
so ideally when we are going to do
single gene disorder
we would like to sequence the disease
mutation and that will
tell us what's going on in the embryonic
level just because if we are using whole
genome amplification
and just by chance is that specific
disease
region that we're interested in is not
amplifying
then we cannot actually give the answer
about the embryonic level
and that's why we use linkage analysis
with the sdr testing
to be able to understand which homolog
chromosome coming from methanol site
to the embryonic level and which homolog
chromosome coming from that
to the embryonic level and based on
using those
uh the sti markers we will be able to
understand
the the embryonic level and whether or
not the ember is affected
or carrier or completely healthy um
when it comes to str analysis they are
typically
we typically develop six or seven str
and
str markers surrounding the disease
mutation so we try to be close
as close as possible to disease mutation
and one of the reason
is to make sure that the crossover
doesn't interfere
with our resulting that cause possible
misdiagnosis
um typically six or seven str is
usually utilized for linkage analysis
and
in some cases combination of direct
mutation analysis as well
now the second approach is linkage
analysis with single neglected
polymorphism for monogenic disorders
and one of the technology that has been
widely used is carrier mapping
with this technology instead of having
repeats that are actually single nuclear
to substitution
and there are approximately four to five
million
uh snips that can be utilized throughout
the whole genome
um and in this case the mom that has
seen that the gg allele and
that has pinky allele and if you put
them in the context of
homozygous a a or homozygous bd and you
would be able to kind of find
the possible alleles in the embryonic
level whether or not they are
a bb with the context of this
current information this again
applies the same thing like ideally we
would like
to sequence the disease mutation if we
can but
uh in case we cannot really have really
nice reading in that specific disease
mutation
then we would be using those sniff
markers
um sniff markers actually has more
frequency
actually they are more common in the
genome again compared to thousands of
thousands sti
we have actually over four or five
million slips throughout the whole
genome
um so as i mentioned in my previous
slide
when we design str markers we try to be
as close as possible
to this mutation but with the sdr
analysis
in some cases we might not be get lucky
and we may not be able to find those str
markers go away
but with the slip they're actually more
powerful
because there are like plenty of them
that to use in the genome
and with this technology with the career
mapping
we are actually able to find close to 30
single neglected polymorphism
flanking region of the disease patient
station obviously
it's better than having only five or six
str markers
um but in case of a little dropout in
case of
we are not able to amplify some of the
dna that we are trying to actually
search for
um half of the the slip markers may not
work
which would end up like getting only 15
or 10 snip markers to work with
which is still not bad but recently
until before i actually jumped into
recent uh ngs technology
for snip analysis i would like to just
quickly
go over carrier mapping with the carrier
mapping you have array
and this array that specific type of
array has a little bit over three
hundred thousand slip markers
but obviously we cannot use all the
three hundred thousand markers because
with this example let's assume that mom
and dad has the same condition and let's
assume that this is a cystic fibrosis
where cystic fibrosis
is autosomal recessive condition where
the mom and dad has the same mutation
and if you think everything is
color-coded in here so let's assume that
that the chromosome actually the blue
has
affected chromosome and the mom the
green one is actually affected
chromosome
which is detected with the star so
depend on
where the diamond or the star goes the
embryo
could be completely affected or could be
carrier like their parents
or could be completely healthy so
depends on where those
stars of diamond goes would be able to
make the analysis in the embryonic level
but again the most important part is
when we look at those snip
markers we need to be able to actually
uh
be as close as possible to the disease
notation
uh we cannot really kind of like look at
those snip markers that are completely
unrelated to chromosomes
um one of the disadvantage with the
carrier mapping is
you are limited whatever is deposited in
the array
so if you have any limitation when you
and when you look at the
specific coverage for the specific
mutation if you don't have enough
snip markers then you might actually
have to use
scr analysis to be able to kind of do
the analysis
since there is not enough coverage for
that specific mutation
now this is the one that i would like to
discuss today uh linkage analysis of
single nucleated polymorphism for
monogenic disease
order with pgtc
it is pretty much identical to snip with
array the only difference is instead of
using array
we're going to be using next generation
sequencing y is important
again this is everything is applied to
what i just explained previously
we tried to do a direct mutation
analysis but in many cases we'll
probably fail or we're not going to get
really
crystal clear up so analysts analyzing
actually those snip markers would be
really important
and one of the advantage by using a pgdc
is we can develop a panel
and we can put as many as snip markers
that we can
put next to the disease mutation and we
typically have 200
snip markers compared to only 30 or
40 markers with array-based technology
and having multiple markers obviously it
increased or
chance of having the confidence level or
include reduce the chance of having this
diagnosis
for possible due to cross agreement
and this is how the workflow works uh
how
the lab protocol work when we
actually do the analysis we use corial
cell lines
and um by
analyzing the cell lines for
pre-implantation genetic testing for
unemployed
indeed as soon as we do the cell lysis
and
extracting the dna and the second step
which is the
right after the pre-amplification we can
take three microliters
a liquid and we can continue in parallel
for pgt set
for single gene disorder and by the time
we are done
pgta and pgtm we will be able to do
simultaneous analysis
uh from the same actual cell lines to be
able to get
the final answer for both
um and we also wanted to
uh understand what if actually we have a
sample with corial cell lines that we
did the verification but the whole
genome modification already completed
now is there any way we can go back and
we do this single gene disorder
this the answer is yes if the sample has
been already done
for an implied screening and we can
always go back
from the third step which is where we
have the amplified library all the
barcoded
barcodes were already actually
incorporated into the sample
if you take 20 micro user alloquats by
purifying
the sample by removing all the barcodes
and primer timers from
the whole genome amplification we will
be able to actually continue with
implantation genetic testing for with
the pgdc and we can still actually do
the analysis
which we did and this is how the
analysis works
and this is again one of the sample that
we receive from corial
cell lines to be able to understand how
the linkage works
this specific example where autosomal
dominant disease the male affected
female came negative from that specific
cell line and we had also maternal dna
from the male which the inheritance
actually
came from a methanol site so everything
is color coded
as you can see female has completely
grayed out
and doesn't have the mutation and male
the the the blue one the ones that
doesn't carry the the mutation and the
orange one the ones that carry
limitations
so when we did the analysis and if you
look at those
um the corial sunlight samples
what we found is the first three samples
that had gotten one chromosome from a
channel size which is definitely
negative
and depending on whether or not we get
the blue or the orange
we will be able to make the calls
whether or not they are carriers or
actually affected
the first three sample as you can see by
chance
the unaffected chromosome was received
from
pathanophyte but the other three samples
they all get actually the affected
chromosome from
a male uh partner with this specific
core cell lines which they are affected
so they're very nice software that
kind of tells you what is going on for
each snips
and this is just like a small screenshot
we typically screen 200 markers
but this is the screenshot just only
show you a few of them
and even if some of the snippets doesn't
work when you work with 200 markers
even a half of them doesn't work we
still have like 100 markers to work with
so um
[Music]
one of the advantages using this ngspgtm
first of all the testing can be
done uh on the resource basis or any
places
it can be done with any mutation with
the with the few exceptions
uh the testing also can be done with the
small deletions or
the insertions if there is a family
pattern and we can do simultaneous
analysis for pgta and pgtm
from the same specimen
and this is the list that
we are able to do for any kind of
genetic testing
mutation analysis but we are not limited
to anything
that is listed in this
mutation list anytime there is an array
of invitation
we can develop the panel and we can
actually target
200 or a little bit over single
nutritive markers
and this is unlike with the array based
technology
if the the disease mutation that we are
looking
in the array platform if there is not
enough snip markers
then that requires to use str analysis
to be able to actually
do the testing when it comes to next
generation sequencing
uh we are not actually depending on
which chromosome and which actually rear
mutation
we can develop and we can actually
target those snip markers
based on the mutation and that we are
receiving
from any specimen
um the terminal runtime is typically
four to
four weeks to develop those panels
[Music]
but one of the again advantage using
pgt sick for monogenic disorder is that
uh unlike the other technologies we are
using 200 markers
uh over 30 markers with cardio mapping
or six
markers with sdr linkage analysis uh but
more importantly
there are some common diseases like such
as cystic fibrosis spinal muscular
atrophy fragile x posterior
imperfecta and alpha telephone those
uh these are quite common in the
population
and there's very much like no waiting
period for those testing so those
actually already
ready in our laboratories and if we want
to do any testing
in any sample we could easily actually
perform without
even a waiting period as long as there
is a informative family members that
can be utilized for linkage analysis but
of course
um if there is
diseases are not covered in the five
disease
we can definitely develop any panel and
that
rare mutation a panel development takes
anywhere between four to six weeks
and simultaneous analysis can be done
with pgta my pgtm from the same sample
and this is going to be my last slide
um we'll continue with using advantage
of pgt
sick we have those ready to use panels
and if the couple has any of those five
disease or any
and the testing can be done easily for
any research base or any
kind of analysis and um
the the one of the also biggest
advantage with pgdc technology
in order to to develop those panels
we are not depending on the family
members
for the prop development so the prop
development candidates can start
independently
again unlike str in order to actually
develop str panel
we the family members are having the
family members first
arrive to the lab is very crucial which
takes some time to collect those
family members to be able to actually do
the linkage analysis
but pgt said uh would be panel
development can start
as soon as we would like to start
and the probe development will take
anywhere from four to six weeks
and the handsome time with the pgt6 it
takes
only four hours and just because of the
liquid handler with iron shaft and we
will be able to do
uh majority of the work without having
actually people hands-on and most of the
work will be done
through the liquid handler and also
sequencing device which is s5
and obviously less human involvement and
less error
and i would like to thank everyone again
who has attended to this meeting
and if there's been a question i'm more
than happy to take one
well thank you dr jenna olu for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question
is can
dna from amniotic sac be used as an
amniosynthesis rather than the dna from
the trophoectoderm of a blastocyst
and the short answer is yes um
yeah any any dna material uh can be
utilized for either
single gene disorders or uh
pre-implanted unit for unemployed
um currently uh we did
analytical verification with corial cell
lines and
as long as the sampler comes from
ambidextrous
cvs chronically like sampling and yes
we can definitely work on those samples
as well
okay great thank you our next question
is
in labs is this performed for checking
some abnormalities in an embryo if the
parent wishes to
um is this for a single gene disorder or
is this
for i need a little bit more
clarification about the question if
or maybe if you repeated it again maybe
i can just have another one i can i can
repeat it again
and then nissa if you want to clarify
you can
type it in again is this performed for
checking some abnormalities in an embryo
if the parent wishes
um yes for pre-implantation genetic
testing for unemployed
yes we do this testing i mean all the
time
um and yes as long as the parent wishes
and there's pretty much like uh all the
requests can be accommodated easily
okay thank you um and lisa if you need
further clarification we'll just type
that in again and we'll
if we don't have time today we'll do
that by email the next question
is okay if if an individual performs
pgta but later finds out one of the
partners has
pgt sr do we need to do another biopsy
or could existing dna be used for pgtsr
testing
that's really yeah that's really great
question
uh yes the there is no need for the
second biopsy
the dna sample that utilized for pgta
can be utilized for pgt sr and there is
no really need for
re-biopsy and we just need to do
actually higher resolution
which again doesn't really require
additional sampling from the same embryo
which is obviously is not ideal to
biopsy embryo twice again the short
answer is yes and can be done
as r without any need for additional
sampling from the same number
okay we've got time for one more
question dr genolu
is the okay i'm not sure how to say this
is the lib prep manual
are also automated um
pretty much everything that i discussed
today in here
is we still use liquid handler which is
iron chef
so the handsome time regardless of pgta
or pgtm the handsome time approximately
three to four hours
the whole protocol takes approximately
16 hours or 17 hours depends on how many
samples we are
running uh but in terms of the the
liquid handler or in terms of like
automation it's pretty much
the same so we just only do a few hours
hands-on and the rest is
always automatic um with the liquid
handlers
and devices
all right well thank you so much dr
janolu do you have any
final comments for the audience today
um yeah i mean those technologies is
relatively new
and uh and like every other year or
every year although i have been in
industry for a long time
every year we learn new things from
either
for any research basis or any for
a published paper so
i have been actually in this field for
last 15 years but again even it makes me
dizzy kind of to see all those kind of
recent advances that's happening in our
field
which i'm really pleased to see those
well thank you again dr genolu for your
time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can also be viewed on
demand lab roots will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye